Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analysegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit ein?
Ja, gerne.
Ich werde Ihnen erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Daten stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Mein Name ist Josef Schmidt.
Mit D, Doppeltee.
Können Sie Ihre Vorname stellen?
J, O, S, E, F.
Ok, Herr Schmidt, wann sind Sie genau geboren und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin am 3.3.1958 geboren und bin 54 Jahre alt.
68, sorry, 3.3.1968 geboren und bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wie groß und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß und bin 80 kg schwer.
80 kg?
Ja, 80 kg, circa.
80?
80, 80.
Ok, ich habe etwas.
Was ist das für uns?
Ich bin heute Morgen zum Einkaufen unterwegs gewesen am Vormittag und auf dem Weg bin ich ausgerutscht und gestürzt.
Seitdem tut mir mein rechter Handgelenk weh.
Genau, ich habe gleich starke Schmerzen.
Ich bin dann direkt hierher gekommen.
Sind Sie auf Ihre Hand ausgerutscht?
Genau.
Ich bin auf eine Hand in den Flächen gefallen.
Haben Sie auch Ihren Kopf gestoßen?
Nein, das war nur mein Handgelenk und auf ein rechtes Knieb bin ich auch drauf gefallen.
Aber da habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Tunten Sie nach den Brusten auf?
Laufen? Ich höre Sie z.B. Ihre Verbindung ist nicht gut.
Ja, ich bin hierher gekommen und danach anschließend.
Haben Sie Ihren Verlust?
Ich hatte keinen Brustensverlust gehabt.
Ich kann mich an alles erinnern.
Haben Sie an Ihren Hand oder hat Ihr eine Wunde bemerkt?
Ich habe eine Schürfwunde in meinem Hand in den Flächen.
Ich habe eine leichte Schürfwunde.
Ich habe nicht viel geblutet, aber es ist nur ein bisschen oberflächlich für Geschürfte.
Haben Sie an Ihrem Hand Taubheit gefühlt?
Nein.
Fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Nein, ich habe nur einen starken Schmerz im Handgelenk.
Ich kann meinen Hand nicht richtig bewegen.
Okay.
Tunten Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen aushalten, wie Sie uns hier gesprochen haben?
Wie bitte?
Tunten Sie die Schmerzen noch ein bisschen aushalten, wie Sie uns hier gesprochen haben?
Ja, ja.
Nur wenn ich bald Bewege tue, wenn ich nicht bewege, beruhigt kalte, dann geht es.
Okay.
Jetzt schmerzen, wie Sie schmerzen auf eine Schmerzsäkler von ein bis zehn,
wobei ein sehr leises, sehr starkes Schmerz entsprechen.
Wo einschätzen Sie die Schmerzen?
Ich würde sagen, wenn ich nicht bewege, habe ich so etwa drei.
Und wenn ich bewege, habe ich etwa acht.
Okay.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in eine andere Gruppe regionaus?
Nein. Das ist ein lokaler Schmerz.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich nichts.
Haben Sie Schütterlfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Hab ich nichts, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut.
Normal.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Nein, nicht wesentlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder mit dem Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Warum fragen Sie, Herr Dr. Ich habe Pankelenchmerzen.
Ich frage mich, ob ich Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen habe.
Problem haben wir mit dem Wasserlassen.
Ich frage mich, um ein Ofen zu erhalten.
Ich frage Sie, ob ich in Ihrem Hand eine Frage habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, eine oder durchzuladen?
Bitte.
Nein, ich habe kein Problem mit dem Schlafen oder Durchschlafen.
Ihre Verbindung, Telefonverbindung ist glaube ich nicht gut.
Ich kann mir ausschalten.
Wie bitte?
Dass ich mir ausschalten will, dass ich hier einstehne.
Sie wollen ausschalten und dann nochmal einschalten oder was?
Mein Karten.
Ich habe schon gesagt, ich könnte dann ein bisschen besser.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, Übelkeit besteht nicht.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, die Verbindung ist jetzt besser.
Erbrochen, nein.
Zu Ihren Schmerzen, ich habe eine Frage vergessen.
Wie ist Ihren Schmerzencharakter?
Oder können Sie Ihren Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumm, stechisch oder...
Ja, das ist ein tochter Schmerz, pulsierender Schmerz manchmal.
Haben Sie an Ihrem Hand eine Verstellung oder komische Bewegung bemerkt?
An der Hand nicht, aber an meinem Handgelenk ist es geschwollen.
Okay.
Ist es zu Ihren Krankengeschichten?
Gibt es Ihnen Ihre Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Wichtige Erkrankungen, also ich nehme nur ein Medikament wegen Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann leiden Sie Artilipotonium, Bluthochdruck?
Seit 15 Jahren ungefähr.
15 Jahre?
Oh, ungefähr.
Wie viel haben Sie dagegen?
Ja, ich nehme dagegen ACE-Hemmer, 10 Milligramm.
Einmal am Tag, das reicht.
Damit komme ich gut raus.
Okay.
Sonst noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte eine Blindam-Operation gehabt in meiner Jugend.
Können Sie wiederholen? Ich habe auch nicht verstanden.
In meiner Jugend hatte ich eine Blindam-Operation gehabt.
Okay.
Ist die Operation komplikationslos gelaufen?
Vor oder nach der Operation, hat man mir gesagt,
damals hatte ich Pädizine bekommen und da habe ich allergische Reaktionen gehabt.
Man hat mir gesagt, dass ich schlechte Luft bekommen habe.
Seitdem darf ich keine Pädizine bekommen.
Haben Sie auch Autoauschlag oder so?
Nur Luftmord entsteht?
Ja, ich kann mich nicht genau erinnern, aber nur Luftmord.
Autoauschlag kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Nehmen Sie sonst weitere Medikamente ein?
Sie haben schon gesagt, ein ACM-Hemal.
ACM-Hemal? Ja, nee, weiter.
Ich nehme ab und zu mal eine Ibuprofen.
Ibuprofen?
Manchmal, wenn ich mal Hoffschmerzen oder irgendwie Schmerzen habe,
nehme ich Ibuprofen bei Beraber, aber das ist nicht meine Regelmedikation.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Nur außer Pädizine kann ich keine Allergien bei mir sein.
Ist nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Unverträglichkeiten, nee, nicht, dass ich höchste.
Brauchen Sie?
Ich schlauche ja.
Seit wann und wie viel hätte ich?
Ich würde sagen seit über 20 Jahren.
10-Skaretten am Tag.
Es ist stark beeindruckend, eine Knochenbuch.
Trinken Sie?
Das Traum beeinträchtigt eine Haarung von Knochenbuch.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke Alkohol.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Sie sind in Ihrer Familie wichtig.
Was ist für Sie wichtig?
Beispiel, bei Ihrer Familie Charlie Burton oder Bluthochdruck,
Blutzucker.
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
auch und meine mutter die ist übergewichtig und nimmt medikamente wegen zucker
ich habe einen bruder ja ich weiß nicht dass er krank wäre dann glaube ich keine medikamente
ja ich bin verheiratet und habe einen so ja Gott sei dank der ist gesund
ja wir wohnen zusammen ich bin maler maler meister herrsch mit ich habe eine frage auch nicht
gesteilt sind sie geimpft gegen insbesondere die tun aus ja ich bin vollständig geimpft
auch über die üblichen krankheiten sei es auch ohne auf wann war lässt der aufwischung es war vor zwei
jahren herrsch mit habe meine ganze frage gestellt haben sie mich fragen oder gehen noch etwas
ein ja doch die geht jetzt weiter sie haben jetzt sehr ausführlich gefragt aber ich habe immer noch
angelenkt was ist denn da ist da etwas gebrochen oder ist da etwas anderes wie geht es jetzt weiter
ja wie gesagt sehr wichtig ich muss bei meinem besieg ich muss bei meinem besieg ich spreche
viel informatis am nach den bisherigen angaben gehe ich von einem knurlbruch aber das blöcke
verdacht ich brauche noch weitere schritten ich muss sie treuperlich untersuchen dann muss ich
ein bildgebende untersuchung wie zum beispiel röntgenaufnahmen ich würde sagen ich würde nicht
ich muss ich würde sagen ich würde gerne ok oder ich möchte gerne erst gerne körperlich
untersuchen dann möchte dann möchte ich da öppen muss ok ok noch mal bitte ich würde wie geht es denn
weiter ich würde sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen dann würde ich manche bildgebende untersuchen
veranlassen wie zum beispiel röntgenaufnahme in ihren arm dann werde ich sie rechtzeitig über
die weitere schritte informieren falls wir andere untersuchen gehen brauchen gebe ich ihnen Bescheid
ok danke schön ok wenn sie keine frage mehr haben ich würde sie körperlich untersuchen
gerne danke
ich würde ich je nach dem befunden wenn es zu einer operations vorbereitung kommen würde aber
einem bestimmten alter würde man eine lumen aufnahme machen für die operat für die
alles sie bereitung labo auch nachmachen damit man die entzündungsferte vorher und nachher
bestimmen kann und verfolgen kann und gerinnungsparameter würden wir machen damit man wenn man operiert
nicht überraschungen erlebt also gut gerinnungsstörung hat ansonsten auch das ist ja wir sind
die monelle ok so wie wir weiter machen gerne ok aber ich möchte heute ihnen eine eine
45 jährige patienten Joseph Schmidt vorstellen der patient steigte sich bei uns wegen seit heute
Morgen bestehende, pochende, nicht ausstrahlende Handgelände in den rechten Handgelände schmerzen,
infolge eine Unfall vor die Schmerzen.
Was für ein Unfall war das? Also wie ist Unfall vor Ort?
Beim Einkaufen weg ist der Patient ausgerutscht.
Auf dem Weg zum Einkaufen?
Auf dem Weg zum Einkaufen ist der Patient ausgerutscht und ist auf den rechten Hand hingefallen.
Anschließend sei die Schmerzen ausgelöst.
Ausserdem sei bei den Patienten an den Innenflächen, hat ihnen vielleicht Schmerzungen oder Schmerzungen.
Ja, Schmerzungen.
Abration, Abration, aufgefallen?
Okay.
Der Patient bewertet den Intensität der Schmerzen mit acht von zehn auf eine Schmerzkala.
Beim Bewegung verschlechtert sich die Schmerzen und klagt der Patient über Schwellung an den rechten Handgelände.
Okay, er klagt zusätzlich Schwellung im rechten Handgelände, okay?
Ja. Die Frage nach Ausstrahlung der Schmerzen wurde verneint.
Die Teternausimpfung vor zwei Jahren sei aufgefrischt worden.
Ja, genau.
Die vegetative Analyse sei unauffällig.
Hat der Patient Probleme, die Finger zu bewegen?
Hat der Motorische Störung?
Ja, ich habe Motorische Störungen.
Oder Taubheitsgefühle in der Hand mit den Finger?
Ja, der Patient leidet keine Taubheitsgefühle oder Parästisien.
Aber eigentlich habe ich nicht Motorische Störungen gefragt.
Aber vermutlich wegen Fraktur kann der Patient nicht mehr bewegen.
Er kann bestimmt sagen Hallo oder ein bisschen bewegen.
Gut.
Der Patient leidet seit fünfzehn Jahren eine Art Elefthomie.
Dagegen nehmen AC Hema 10 mg einmal pro Tag ein.
Bei den Patienten sei in Jugend eine Apandieckomie erfolgt worden.
Die Operation sei komplikationslos verlaufen.
Außer AC Hema nehmen der Patient bei Bedarf über Profen ein.
Der Patient habe Allergie gegen Penicillin, die sich durch Dyspne ausreitet.
Der Patient raucht seit über 20 Jahren 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Die Fragen, Alkohol und Drogenkonsum wurde verneinnt.
Die Familien sind an einem Nächstig sein Artelle-Hypertonie beim Vater.
Über Gewichtigkeit und Alkohol.
Und die wird es mit den Typen bei der Mutter.
Der Patient habe einen Bruder, der ist gesund.
Der Patient sei gesund.
Der Patient sei verheiratet, habe kein Kinder.
Ich habe ein Sohn, der gesund sein und lebe mit Familie.
Er arbeitet als Malermeister.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf Handgelenfraktur.
Insbesondere Radiusfraktur entsteht Meister.
Differenzialdiagnostik kommen andere Hand, Wurzelknochen, Frakturen in Betracht.
Zur weiteren Abkulierung würde ich folgende Massnahmen durchführen.
Erstens würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich insprichiere die Hand, ob es Schwellungen gibt, wie die Abkultation oder Schnürfungen.
Ob es eine Verstellung gibt.
Ich taste die Pulse und prüfen die Arterelle Versorgung.
Sie heben den Versprutungsstatus der Hand.
Ich würde auch überprüfen, ob es eine Tat- heitgefühle oder Parästisien und motorischen Defiziten gibt.
Zur Bestätigung der Verdachtdiagnose sollte ich Röntgenaufnahme in zwei Ebenen an den Handgelenk eingeleitet werden.
Ich würde einleiten oder durchführen lassen.
Bei Bestätigung der Verdachtdiagnose soll ich Schonung, Kühlung, Stabilisierung und Hochlagerung empfehlen oder durchführen.
Die Therapieempfehlung ist immer zwei Sachen.
Die eine Sache ist die konservative Therapie und die andere ist die operative Therapie.
Wenn man nach Fraktur oder Frakturdisklikation empfehlen würde, würde man eine Dorsale unterarmend Gipschiene anlegen.
Wenn es möglich ist, dann würde man die operative Therapie aufklären.
Dann würde man eine operative Aufklärung durchführen, die Risiken aufklären, bezüglich der Chirurgie.
Dann würde man bitten, dass der Anäzisist vorbeikommt und eine Aufklärung durchführt.
Wenn man eine operative Vorgene empfehlen würde, würde man weitere Untersuchungen machen.
Es wäre eine Vorbereitung, wie EKG-Aufnahme, Anäzisik oder Laboraufnahme.
Wenn man die OP-Procedere vor dem Termin hat, oder wenn es sehr stark geschwollen ist,
rückstellt und nach abschwellenden Maßnahmen die Operation durchschüttet.
Das hängt davon ab, ob eine sehr starke Stellung da ist.
Bei der ersten Empfehlung ist es wichtig, nicht nur, dass man eine unterarmend Gipschiene macht,
sondern man wird auch ründgen Verlaufskontrollen durchengmarschig.
Nach einer Woche, nach zwei Wochen und nach vier Wochen.
Was für eine Fraktur würden Sie erfahren bei Handgelängsfrakturen?
Meine Erfahrungen fragen Sie.
Sie sagen, wie ist der Patient gefallen?
Der ist auf die Hand gefallen?
Ja, richtig.
Das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Frakturen bei Handgelängsfrakturen?
Ja, die Patientin ist auf Innenfläche hingefallen.
Das heißt, in diesem Fall kann ein tolles Fraktur entstehen.
Genau, richtig.
Wenn der Patient Handbrücken hingefallen ist, kann ein Smithfraktur entstehen.
Ich habe mir für euch als Esilsbrücke gemerkt.
Bei Handgelängsfrakturen ist eine Dorsalextension.
Dadurch entsteht ein C, also ein tolles Fraktur.
Exztenzionsfraktur sind tolles Fraktur C.
Das ist eine Esilsbrücke.
Man kann sich gut merken, wer ist das Smith und wer ist das Kolles.
Ich habe das eben gerade erwähnt.
Oder frage ich es gerade nochmal.
Wie würde man eine tolles Fraktur sonst beschreiben?
Eine andere Name.
Nicht eine Erfindername, sondern einen Erfindername.
Das ist eine Extztenzionsfraktur.
Genau, das würde man sagen.
Also man sagt Extztenzionsfraktur.
Ein Distalle, zum Beispiel eine Distalle, Radius, Extztenzionsfraktur.
Wenn man noch genauer sagt, eine Distalle, Radius, Extztenzionsfraktur
mit Gelenkbeteiligung oder ohne der Gelenkbeteiligung.
Und dann noch genauer würde man sagen, eine distalere Radius,
Extztenzionsfraktur mit Gelenkbeteiligung.
Oder eine nicht distalere Radius, Extztenzionsfraktur
ohne Gelenkbeteiligung.
Das würde heißen konservative Maßnahmen.
Das müsst ihr jetzt nicht wissen, wenn im Gelenk eine Fraktur ist,
muss man nicht immer mehr.
Das müsst ihr jetzt nicht wissen, wenn im Gelenk eine Fraktur ist, muss man nicht immer operieren, wenn die Gelenkfläche etwa 2 mm, das ist jetzt nichts des Fachwissen,
eine Distokation von mehr als 2 mm ist, eine Stufe ist, dann empfiehlt man schon eine Operation, weil es zu einer frühzeitigen Arthrose entstehen kann im späteren Verlauf des Dienstes.
Wenn man eine instabile Fraktur gibt, dann würde man auch operieren.
Beispiel, Stiloidfrakturen, Stammfrakturen.
Das ist das zweite nochmal.
Stammfrakturen, ich habe das fast gesagt, oft auch schon.
Dann fragt du, der kennt nicht Kassidismus.
Stammfrakturen, okay. Impressionsfraktur, weil wir über die Justus.
Impression oder Winner, das ist das.
Die distizierte Fraktur oder Gelenkbeteiligung mit Stufenbildung, oder instabile Frakturen, sagt man auch, oder mehr Fragmentfrakturen, sagt man auch, würde man meistens operieren,
mittels einer Platte und Spaubend.
Ja.
Okay.
Alles klar. Also von meiner Seite, alles klar.